when we think of classic works of art
the most common setting we imagine them
in is a museum but what we often forget
is that much of this art was not
produced with a museum setting in mind
what happens to an artwork when it's
taken out of its originally intended
context take the example of
Michelangelo's Statue of David depicting
the boy hero who slew the giant
Philistine Goliath armed with only his
courage and his slingshot
when Michelangelo began carving a block
of pure white marble to communicate this
famous biblical story the city of
Florence intended to place the finished
product atop their grand Cathedral not
only with the 17 foot tall statue be
easily visible at this height but it's
placement alongside 11 other statues of
Old Testament heroes towering over
onlookers would have a powerful
religious significance forcing the
viewer to stare in awe towards the
heavens but by the time Michelangelo had
finished the work in 1504 the plans for
the other statues had fallen through and
the city realized that lifting such a
large sculpture to the roof would be
more difficult than they had thought
furthermore the statue was so detailed
in lifelike down to the bulging veins in
David's arm and the determination on his
face that it seemed ashamed to hide it
so far from the viewer a council of
politicians and artists convened to
decide on a new location for the statue
ultimately voting to place it in front
of the Palazzo della signoria the Town
Hall and home of the new Republican
government this new location transformed
the statues meaning the Medici family
who for generations had ruled the city
through their control of banking had
recently been exiled in Florence now saw
itself as a free city threatened on all
sides by wealthy and powerful rivals
David now the symbol of heroic
resistance against overwhelming odds was
placed with his intense stare now a look
of stern warning focused directly
towards Rome the home of Cardinal
Giovanni de Medici though the statue
itself had not been altered its
placement changed nearly every aspect of
it from a religious to a political
significance though a replica David
still appears at the palazzo the
original statue was moved in 1873 to the
galleria delicate amia where remains
today in the orderly quiet environment
of the museum alongside numerous
half-finished michelangelo sculptures
overt religious and political
interpretations fall away giving way to
detached contemplation of Michelangelo's
artistic and technical skill but even
here the astute viewer may notice that
David's head in hand appeared
disproportionately large
a reminder that they were made to be
viewed from below so not only does
context change the meaning and
interpretation of an artwork throughout
its history sometimes it can make that
history resurface in the most unexpected
ways